it's a time-honored thing to put your
name on your artistic productions
writers have their name on the book
painters write their name in the corner
why couldn't video game designers have
their name in their games
this is a story about one man who took
on a giant tech company and changed the
gaming world in the process
[Music]
my name is warren robinette i'm the
creator of adventure the first action
adventure game this was a video game
that i wrote working for atari in the
late 70s
they treated us badly in several
different ways no royalties no name on
the box no external recognition
being told that we were easily
replaceable
they disrespected us
so warren hatch the perfect plan what i
did was i hid my name in the game in a
secret room that was really hard to get
to
when you got in there the screen filled
up with a flashing movie marquee that
said created by warren robinette atari
shipped out two hundred thousand copies
of adventure before anyone discovered
warren's secret room how did they find
out about that
a fifteen-year-old boy in salt lake city
wrote a letter to atari and he very
clearly explained how to get into the
secret room and warren wasn't worried at
all about repercussions what are they
going to do take away my royalty well
they weren't giving us any royalties a
firemen so happened that i'd already
quit
but to warren's surprise his active
rebellion was well received by atari's
new lead game designer steve wright
he's musing to himself about this
situation and he said it was kind of
cool to have hidden surprises in video
games it's like waking up on easter
morning and going out and finding
colored easter eggs under the bushes and
flowers
everything ended alright for warren
robinette
you can't say the same for atari atari
actually
collapsed in one year it imploded
personally i think there's some poetic
justice there that the big powerful rich
new york pushy guys could not defeat the
one little 26 year old programmer who
just had a sneaky idea and pulled it off
without telling anybody
[Music]
you